[Musique]
toulon guinée ça va commencer
c'est là
à
[Musique]
là
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
je alors j'ai une beauty un peu du
labour après que je te montrer c'est
simple parce que d'une particularité sur
le sourire le voyage et son dj oui
collection l'un vient de hong kong
l'autre assez de l'inde la grèce et
l'ecosse oui ils se ressemblent tous ah
oui parce que je le descends toujours
dans la même chambre d'hôtel au complet
regards ils sont magiques apache ah oui
alors j'y reviens pas
et ce n'est pas tout car si tu te
trouves dans un hôtel et si tu veux
étonner la femme de chambre tu
l'appelles et alors là je te recommande
cette chose là tu prends un sainte
henriette eu le place au dessus de
l'autre tu fais deux et alors tu ne peux
pas rester comme ça donc en ce moment là
essaye de le retirer
turp et non écoute je n'y comprends rien
du tout à l'heure jacques michel où il
ya de lâcher deux parties
alors tu ne peux quand même pas rester
comme ça donc si tu as vraiment trop de
problèmes je sais ce que tu fais tu
appelles le directeur études y regarder
aux cinq sens sont magiques et voilà et
tu le retires oui j'insiste pour vincent
simard ont alors vécu mais regarde
maintenant si je veux brison système
alors là je ne veux pas de risques parce
que si tu as mal aux oreilles c'est toi
qui le recrutera de la merci à ben non
c'est rare que nous retenons on peut
surtout s'attacher patients cherchés pas
pensez pas
[Musique]
gérard oui j'ai faim tout costume et un
bâton qu'est ce que c'est qu'est ce que
c'est que ça
[Musique]
à
vous
e
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
woodford tôt possible
oui
[Musique]
non bien sûr ok ok
bah
tonton
[Musique]
bon
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
tous
ah ah
[Musique]
oui
troy
m
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et
[Musique]
aujourd'hui c'est un truc avec des
cartes à jouer
un truc oui chicala très facile d'accord
denis prend une carte n'importe laquelle
oui tu te souviendras bien pose là quand
ça te fait plaisir très bien et
maintenant pour retrouver cette carte
nous allons tenter quelque chose de très
simple on prend le jeu on le lance sur
la table et là il se coupe à une seule
car c'est le set de carreaux et là c'est
ta carte
oh bah écoute alors eh bien il y a un
truc qui se résume à peu de choses
mais oui c'est du salon alors lancé
pascal ya une carte truc et je vous
montrer comment la religion se presser
un compte-rendu gros sel voilà et avec
la colle ont fait quatre petits points
de colle sur une carte à jouer
et sur chaque point de colle en place un
grain de brossard attendait là vous ne
voyez pas très bien alors j'ai apporté
une grosse carte voilà sans grandes et
mieux compte 1 voilà les grains que vous
voyez ici sont collés à quatre points
évidemment une petite carte ça ne se
voit pas alors la façon de procéder
ensuite est très simple vous placez la
carte à jouer tout le jeu comme ceux ci
sur le jeu alors une carte est choisi
par exemple le 8 de trèfle on coupe le
jeu est en place la carte choisie ici
maintenant entre place le reste du jeu
mais attention la carte riquet se trouve
ici est ainsi l'espace constitué par les
grains de sel va permettre le miracle en
lançant le jeu pas tout à fait
verticalement main tout petit peu de
travers regardez ce qui se produit le
jeu sorte de temps en temps il se
retourne la moitié du jeu the town ou
alors sans totalement comme ça ça dépend
de la force avec lequel on lance et
alors là vous avez vraiment la carte qui
se trouve là les huit de trêve nicolas
toi quand tu le fais tu en entends je
tourne un oui mais pour ça moi j'ai ma
botte secrète
ah bon en bas pendant alors je te le
fait que le suspect
merci et sept vols secrets c'est
vraiment un trésor alors il faut bien le
protéger
encore une voie là encore les autres
j'ai une tolérance j'ai quelques petits
ressorts magique et j'en prends un que
je pose d'un ressort magique je le vois
pas et je les fais demande et agnès deux
premiers car tu vois là et maintenant je
couple je vois là et je prends le petit
ressort que je trouve qu'ici je pousse
sur ma carte et je remets le radiateur
dessus voilà
et maintenant je laisse le pape est est
ce que cela vous avez qu à une autre
façon de faire ce tour mais alors là
avec un truc que je ne vous expliquerai
pas et de tenir le jeu comme ceux ci est
de demander à l'un d'entre vous ne
jetons pas changer un petit peu et elle
regarde tu me le dis maintenant une
perte celle que tu veux tu regardes bien
mon jeu c'est le quart de tu as de prêt
cap de trêve alors regardez bien je fais
un petit mouvement sur le jeu et si je
lâche mon doigt regarde le jeu avance
tout seul et si je retourne il n'ya pas
de cadre de trèfle ici et là la première
carte est justement le cas de trèfle
bravo et l
[Musique]
à
houas
[Musique]
à
et
[Musique]
oh
bon
[Musique]
ans
bon
[Musique]
regarde t on des moments
pour des bobos
pour compenser
[Musique]
messieurs
non
et les bobos
et nous les bonbons dans la balle bien
comment ça va finir pas si évident oui
mais on garde
la coop ça je vais voir tu vas pas
d'insuline
y a rien dedans
elle est vide à lévis avant vient
[Musique]
tout madame
ouais
[Musique]
oh
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
non
dites moi
son passé les bonbons et les bonbons
[Musique]
sont pas là demain
non non très bien
abracadabra
[Musique]
à l'approché tout